the big problem is basically China
itself that is it is slowing down its
rate of growth quite dramatically and
everyone who looks at the data will tell
you we're not quite sure which data are
real and which or not I do think that
this seven to seven and a half percent
annual rate of growth is unachievable I
think that what is happening is as as
China's productivity Edge's ever closer
to the level of that exists in the
United States the gap closes and the
ability to search to close the gap is
more and more difficult which means that
you're going to get a convergence
between productivity in the United
States and particularly in China much
more closely and that means it's going
to be a big slowdown in China as part of
that convergence a currency not war but
a renminbi devaluation or depreciation
which leads us to a dollar like the late
90s so-called Rubin dollar or like a
Plaza Accord dollar strength this is
where the issues lie I don't know the
answer to them and I do say the United
States and crucially US dollar
unquestionable is the firmest er
currency in the world of the major
countries it's hard to see where it goes
from who knew there were so many huge
unknowns which in my experience I've
never seen this many unknowns is there a
real problem that we can put our finger
on with dodd-frank right now or is it
also an unknown the regulations are
supposed to be making changes of
addressing the problems that existed in
2008 or leading up to 2008 it's not
doing that the too-big-to-fail has been
the critical issue back then and now and
there's nothing in dodd-frank
any of its two changes that they've made
which actually addresses this issue are
you optimistic going forward here no I
haven't been for quite a while and I
won't be until we can resolve the
entitlement programs nobody wants to
touch it but it's gradually crowding out
capital investment and that's crowding
out productivity and that's crowding out
the standards of living what do you want
me to go from there